Do Do.
Doot,
doot,
Doo.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you,
you wherever you are,
a treadmill,
the car,
the airport,
the bathroom you brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link for the flashlight and entering the code name,
Rogan.
You will get 15% off the number one sex toy for men and then you could shoot
loads in it knowing that you're saving money.
Freddy Loc card is in the building.
Buckle up,
bitches.
Here we go.
Thought you're going to get the girl today
for Freddy.
Happy Sunday.
Happy Shark Week
and started going every three months.
Man,
they're wearing that shark week out.
Freddie Lockhart is in the building.
Please.
John,
one of the only humans that I know that says son more than I do.
I say sunny.
Great today son.
I say by myself when I'm in the car,
when I see dudes on the phone get off the phone son and they get the phone up to
their ear,
which is illegal under California law.
I wonder how many fucking people have died directly as a result of idiots being
on their phone.
Texting and driving and talking on the phone with butter ear and losing it.
The peripheral vision.
I bet it's staggering numbers.
It's a lot worse than I thought it was you at first.
I always like,
oh,
it's probably the worst.
It's like eating or doing other things in the car,
but now there's so many times they're just at the stop light.
Like really stop Facebooking.
It's a green light.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people that just won't let that shit drop.
I have to make up like that.
I was trying to send a tweet on the way here.
I'm like on,
you know your winding mountain road almost dying the tweet.
Isn't that how they thought that Paris Hilton was a Paris Hilton's plastic
surgeon,
but it sounded so good.
I don't know why they ever clarified it.
It's just leave it out there.
Right.
You know,
he was all over the cliff and Mallon tweeted about his dog and then a couple
seconds later died and they were thinking that he was tweeting.
While he's driving,
but they don't know.
He could have been reading his tweets.
Know he might not have been actually driving,
but how the fuck do you go off a cliff?
Especially if you had written that cliff many a times.
I know Laurel Canyon like the back of my hand,
I can try to call unless you think you're in a goddamn Porsche commercial and
you're going sideways around corners.
There's this video that made me want to get a GT three before it go on is a,
there's a video of a Porsche on a mountain road.
It's a gt three and a mountain road at some bad ass fucking rally driver and
he's on a mountain road and it's like turning left and right.
He's going sideways around every corner.
Just knows what the fuck he's doing knows how to handle that thing and it looks
so much fun.
You got One?
Yeah,
I got to gt three.
I got rid of that Barracuda.
Well did you?
Yeah,
we can never drove it.
Just know for sure.
Well,
I never drove it anyone out for shows the first six months that I add it.
And then it almost killed me.
I talked,
I've talked about this many times on the show.
So in the interest of brevity,
the,
when I got home one day,
the suspension fell off in the driveway,
the suspension detached from the frame.
And I was like,
what the fuck?
That could have happened like 10 minutes ago when I was going 70 miles an hour
on the highway and I'd be a dead person.
That's like a quarter million dollar.
Yeah.
Well it didn't cost me that much,
but it's probably worth that much.
Like I got rid of it and I'm like,
no,
I sold it to a dude.
Did I know some rich character?
You drive it around?
Yeah,
he,
he's uh,
he owns like a big,
uh,
Ferrari refurbishing place.
He loves cars and he's got an undercarriage to every once in awhile.
In fact,
James like the sandwich,
I pay white pink,
give him a hundred bucks,
given everybody a hundred bucks to watch it.
And then one of the dudes that I gave a hundred bucks,
now it's one of the cameraman for TMC.
So he comes down.
Yeah.
He goes down to the Improv and I'm like,
what's up dude?
I was like,
yeah,
you remember you used to make me cry in your car for $100.
It's a terrible impression of him.
I don't know why.
You know what?
That's all he deserve.
Some guys like
in a bad dude,
it's just a little on the shy side on the extremely likely,
like you walked in,
like I wasn't drinking up
z a comic cause he tried to be calm.
He's a nice guy.
You know.
I actually even live in the same park.
I don't want to say live in the same room,
not in the same room with
you and wheels live in the same apartment.
One time
after I'd moved out,
I've lived in meals.
This house,
you might've been written,
somebody else's house,
you don't even know.
I was there for like a month.
And then I moved into Kelly endos house and then those guys later on
and I'm like,
you know,
he's one of those weird weird guys.
If you don't know who we're talking about,
this,
this comic named wheels.
And,
uh,
he used to open for dice clay back in the day and his claim to fame,
you can have it on his website was the night nice.
Couldn't follow him.
He killed so hard can fund.
We can be the fuck are you talking about?
Like if you've never seen dice performed love or hate dice.
Dice is a God damn pro.
Nobody does.
Nobody goes on and like,
I can't,
yeah,
I can't fall away.
It's impossible.
It's never happened ever.
But this dude,
it's awesome.
His stories or I don't want to call him a compulsive liar,
but that's the only description of fence.
Grandiosity.
We did the La Jolla once and he was like a,
you know I was professional pool player.
He's telling me he's a professional pool player.
Really?
He goes,
oh yeah,
I hustled.
I,
you know,
I go,
dude,
I didn't know that.
I go,
I've been looking for someone to play pool with.
Come Out,
let's play pool.
It's like a dollar game.
Do those would be like 30 bucks.
I won 30 games in a row.
I'm like,
this is ridiculous.
Where were you playing pro?
Cause I'm going to go over there and started robbing people.
He never got out once,
never got out once.
I'll tell you one thing.
He said he's a hell of a cook.
No,
I have ever had a spoon.
Yes,
I did.
He catered and he brought it to the comedy store and it was really good.
Yeah,
but I don't want to believe he made it.
I want to be with his fucking stolen from some Mexican dude.
He got some pork.
I work on a farm for five bucks an hour next time.
There's a lot of those guys in Hollywood,
man,
and he wouldn't need a lot of guys that just completely,
totally full of shit.
She knows something when you're on their level.
It takes me a while to figure that out.
Here's an Harvard to figure it out.
I'm just like,
you know,
especially now,
it's like I have the Internet.
Yeah.
Well now the problem is they've established a long tradition of line throughout
their whole life
and it helps to create this world that they want to live.
Well.
I think it's a lot of it is also just impulsive.
The liars that I've known.
It seems like they just can't help it.
Like they have a hard time not lying.
You know what's the weirdest is successful liars like or the,
I'm not a name any names,
but there's comics.
Yeah.
Hell
yeah.
I love Eddie Griffin.
Eddy Griffin's but then the back of the comedy,
I wants
how many?
Eight rounds yesterday.
We don't world champion kickboxer and I'm going to tell you what,
for the first three rounds for the first three rounds and they was getting the
best of me,
but for the last five he didn't want none of this
cigarette.
In one hand I'm drinking the other and meanwhile this guy's a movie star there.
He'll tell you things Nigga,
when I was studying at Harvard and before,
yeah,
but after Oxford and before Johns Hopkins I said,
Eddie,
I'm going to do some comedy.
It was like,
the thing is he was a very talented dude.
Yeah,
brilliant dude.
It's like he had all of these attributes,
but then he would just like,
oh Nigga been to the moon.
I'm like,
I'm sure you have not been to the moon.
I don't think you have.
He's a liar movie star.
Yeah,
and that's what I don't get it.
It's like you're at you.
You've knocked it out of the park.
Did something that 0.001% people in this town do congratulations.
And here you're trying to tell me that you own coca cola to like come on.
He's so crazy.
I'm already impressed.
But that's why he's so talented.
He can just get on stage and just talk shit.
He's one of the few guys that I've ever seen that will get on stage and not have
a fucking clue as to what he's going to talk about.
Right.
And he'll stay up there for five hours and he always did.
It's like I'd always extract one thing I liked from a comic,
even if I didn't like that comic very much as he could pass.
Can think of it as next step is like,
man,
just hang.
I would say yeah,
just face and smoke and stare.
Oh,
also let it seem like you were supposed to be dwelling on the last oh deep shit
hit you.
Like he just just inundating you with an avalanche of analytics.
Like,
Oh my God,
let me come up from the promote that we're exposed to.
But being comics and by being comics in the pressure cooker that is Hollywood,
you're exposed to psychological lessons at the average person just never gets to
deal with.
Right.
You know,
you get to watch someone become crazy,
get to watch someone,
you get to watch someone lose their,
when they get a little bit of fame.
Those guys are fascinating.
You know the people that get a little development deal and all of a sudden a
yelling at people and ordering people around.
And do you know the best story that the story of the Boondock Saints,
the kid,
the truck up,
dude,
we have talked about this on the podcast very recently.
This is documentary right there night.
That's the perfect example.
Yes.
Except for the folks that don't know this guy that made the movie,
the Boondock Saints,
and they made a documentary on him called overnight and he's just an
insufferable cunt of a human being who got some success.
Right.
And fucked it all up.
Success though I haven't heard of since then in Hollywood,
like,
like they bought the bar,
the kid worked at,
they didn't come.
They promised it was part of the deal.
Miramax Harvey Weinstein promise to buy him the bar and then Cole on the bar,
because that was back then when they had hopes that like,
hey,
Ben Affleck and Matt Damon did it.
We can,
we're star makers now.
We're,
we're,
we're going to take an scripts and make them big.
That was the added their thing in the mid,
late nineties Miramax,
they're huge into that and so I was like,
yeah,
they can't get that deal.
And he's talking like people are lining up to make,
I haven't seen that kind of heat around the script since then.
The dudes who were lining up to get in that all Boston Irish dukes were like
really clamoring to get in there and then it started to whittle down to all you
have is Willem defoe who was in it from the beginning,
but like that's the only guy I think he was stayed at.
Can you see the movie though?
Man?
It just,
it's an amazing documentary on what,
what can happen to,
you can add it all.
Yeah.
You can lose your shit,
man.
There's a lot of people,
I've met so many people that have just completely lost their shit along the way
too.
Just mediocre success.
Just a little tiny bit.
When you see them,
you know,
letting,
you know they got $1 million guarantee and there's fucking show they're going to
put it on right after.
Friends are always going to fail.
We're in,
but don't you think it's funny though,
like in the grand scheme of things that the bigger they are,
usually the cooler are like a Tom Hanks.
It's probably not a decade.
You know what I mean?
Or some of them.
Yeah.
Or say in the world of comedy,
Chris Rock shows up to the comedy story shows up alone with a notebook.
Ask us if he can go on.
Right.
You know,
and he's,
you know,
arguably the top comic in the world,
at least one of the most recognized right now.
Take somebody who's like maybe the 156 best comic in the world,
but men steal.
Yeah,
something like that.
What I will get on stage and Bogart and go on pat and showing up to a war
theater.
It's like you can't,
you know if the number one guys exercising that he much humility,
everybody below needs to follow suit.
It's a,
it's a,
an amazing dance that you play when you're trying to get attention on stage
because you're trying to get these people to look at you.
So you're trying to like perform the most entertaining set possible and the best
way possible,
but in some way or another and you have to divert all that adulation away from
yourself.
You have to figure out a way to accept it and then like turn it right back to
the people and you can't bathe in it.
You can't like take it seriously.
I think that you are the shit or you will suck.
Then you got to remember too,
we're not saving fucking life.
You know what I mean?
And that's like another thing too.
It's like with comedy,
but you have so many other interests.
It's like we have 23 and a half hours a day to spare.
You can either become just a fucking miserable prick or you can educate yourself
or pick up another passion,
you know,
and it's like,
oh,
you can become completely obsessed with your career.
Exactly quotes and not have any other thing that you turn to and then lose your
shit.
Cause to be a career.
A law allows you to do all the other things you wanted to do.
It's like,
okay,
now I have a pass to do the other things I want to do.
There's a,
uh,
an interesting thing that Mark Marin just did.
He did this keynote speech at a,
the just for laughs and I listened in on it cause I have this sort of love hate
thing with Ma'am Marin helped me out when I was an open miker and uh,
gave me some real solid advice and real solid compliments.
And uh,
I remember,
you know,
Colin been doing comedy for a real short period of time,
less than a year.
And Marin was established and I was like,
wow,
I can't believe this guy just,
you know,
just totally pumped me up.
And I was like,
I can fucking do this.
You know,
I've,
I felt like,
you know,
I got,
from a guy like that who was real stingy with compliments through,
you know.
Yeah.
So for years I've been trying to be so fucking nice to him,
like,
because of that note,
so every opportunity to shit on him or to fuck with him,
I've avoided and ducked because I felt like I owed him for something that
happened when we were really young.
And so,
um,
you know,
that's why I did his podcast,
even though he had said some stupid shit about me and doesn't even know me.
Like we need to have conversations and like,
what did they say about you?
Oh,
just said,
he said a bunch of really dumb shit.
One of the things about that,
one of the really dumb things that he said is that,
uh,
I've done more bad to comedy than men.
Sia has because of doing fear factor and his rationale.
This is a true argument.
His rationale was that in doing fear factor,
I had taken work away from standup comics who also worked as writers.
So the idea is that in me being a standup comic who also has a side job of
hosting somehow or another,
these other standup comics,
their side job of writing sitcoms outside of standup comedy,
their side job is somehow or another more valid that it's still,
it's still not comedy,
it's none.
Let stand up comedy.
So you're talking about a guy who,
a massive plagiarist who just ruined comics' lives and you're comparing them to
me because our hosting a game show.
But this,
watching this,
listening to this keynote,
now I understand a little bit better because three years ago he was talking
about how he was so depressed he couldn't get any road work.
He couldn't,
couldn't get booked anywhere and no one wanted to have meetings with them.
Nothing was going on.
And you know,
he was thinking about committing suicide.
And this is just three years ago,
it was before he started doing his podcast.
And you know,
this is all the shit was going down.
I mean,
this is,
you know,
three years ago I wasn't doing fear factor,
but I'm sure before then the bitterness was just as much.
When some people see other people get success,
they fester and it drives me fucking crazy.
And they want to look for holes in it to want to look for things that are wrong
with it.
Instead of saying,
Oh,
look at that fucking guy,
he's going to do it.
Like,
like,
I love drew Carey.
Okay,
I wouldn't want to host the price is right for a fucking million dollars an
episode.
I'd be like,
God damn,
that's what he's doing.
The price is right or is that,
uh,
he took over Bob Market.
But you know what that shows me that you,
you're a creature who is survival of the fittest.
When this business changes,
you adapt.
Well,
let's see.
No,
he decided to take a job.
This is what I looked at it.
I mean,
look who drew Carey's your great personality.
He's a warm,
friendly guy.
You know,
like,
what's the other guy's name?
The the black dude who sings
Brady?
Yeah.
What's his name?
Wayne Brady.
Wayne,
why don't want to call them?
Well,
I've kitten his hand as smoke,
too much weed.
But anyway,
he,
when he does his show,
which one is he doing?
He's doing one of those daytime shows too.
What was he doing?
A talk show.
Yeah,
and one of those fucking price is right or the other one
name that tune whatever the fuck is doing.
It's not good.
And it's,
it's one of those things where you look like it's like soul crushing shit,
right?
It's just a fucking Gig.
When I see drew Carey,
I don't go to fucking drew Carey sold out look who could drive your persona.
But Marin has this thing because he was so unsuccessful.
He looks for reasons why other people success is either invalid or,
or negative or bad.
But this,
this fucking festering personality of constantly obsessing about his career and
negativity is,
it was a fascinating,
the keynote,
one of the things he said that he joked around,
it was a really funny joke,
but he,
I'm the guy who thought,
Louise,
a TV show should have been called.
Fuck you,
Mark Marin know because they started out together.
You know,
it's got some fucking crazy jealous and it's about Louie.
Then he's up in Boston or in New York.
Yeah,
I knew in Boston when I was an open Mike.
He was at same kind of with me and he was always busy.
Khan to everybody.
It's a country.
Jamie kills teas and kind of to Ari Shapiro.
This Brian Callen wanted to beat him up.
Oh,
he's been a cut to me.
He's a cunt.
And the reason why he's a Qantas cause he's a cunt to himself.
He's not happy with the,
is a really nice guy.
Nice guy.
Ever.
He insulted,
count on stage in front of Accountants,
friends who came to see him in New York.
Not a disrespect.
Cowan wanted to kill him.
You know,
Kellen even like said something and threatened to him and said,
look and I,
I'll hit you like,
okay,
you want to fuck with me and fucking mean front of my friends.
Like I'll hit you.
I don't know what happened or who he just was,
just the stories that I'm getting.
But I know that he gave Ari unsolicited criticism and I know he fucks with
Kilstein Brian and you fucking with the levels constantly tweaking your fucking
with my head Bro.
Leave it alone.
But why's he doing that?
Who's doing that?
Cause he's doing that to himself.
His whole mind is fucked.
He's a guy who's been doing comedy for forever but still can't get successful.
We were in Irvine the other day,
we did the Irvine Improv and I'm like,
uh,
do you guys pretty much sell out here every weekend?
It's not one mark man was here.
It was like a barely go to a hundred tickets sold each show and I was like a
hundred tickets at the Irvine Improv.
Like that's impossible.
So it's like this,
this,
this career that he's had for all these years,
25 plus years.
It's,
you know,
he's obviously done a lot of shit wrong until we did this podcast and this
podcast and you just nail it.
Podcasting figured out what he's good at is really getting into people's minds.
She knows his own neurosis is he knows his own,
his own fears and hopes and dreams.
And stand up and he can relate to other comics.
And then now he's sort of like calming down and being,
but he still does do she shit.
Like Anthony Bourdain is going to be on my podcast.
Oh seriously?
Yeah.
And he wrote uh,
Hey,
I heard you're going to do Rogan's podcast but he ain't me.
You know,
it would be deep.
I like to go and that's exactly what he ain't me.
It would be deep like,
come on man,
go go take a Goddamn Yoga class.
Go to one of those places where everybody just hugs everybody,
you know what I mean?
Just go and get some hugs,
man.
What the what the eff,
this negative fostering fucking kind of thinking is exactly what we're talking
about where people don't have shit outside of their career and if they don't
have a bunch of other things,
if you have something going on,
I could care less about what's going on with others that they never taken away
from me.
You're not taking work away from me,
which nobody is.
Nobody is,
you know,
I'm fine with that.
And it's like I that comedy cop thing to me and about a year into comedy when
it's like,
holy crap,
I've got my own thing to say now I'm going to be concerned with who goes on for
me,
what goes on after me.
I don't care.
Well,
it's another thing that Marin had said on the show once about his,
uh,
his parents never fostered a healthy sense of competitiveness in him.
And he's one of those guys that like if he's losing,
he'll just turn the board over.
I'm just fucking take your ball and go home.
And it's that,
that crazy sort of fucking dysfunctional thinking that,
that thinking that this disconnected is what it is.
You're disconnected from other people and you want it all.
You want all the adulation.
You want all the love.
And if you're not getting what you need,
fuck everybody else.
Then negativity starts.
You start throwing your negativity at other people.
And the only way you can truly be positive at all is if you feel like you're
getting enough positivity to be okay.
I've got a good level here.
I got a good stash of positivity.
Now I can be nice.
It's a fascinating psychological study to watch all these guys to watch these
mark Marin guys said were like literally on the brink of suicide,
you know,
and I think I tried to like mark.
I really do.
I try to be nice to him as much as I can.
I try to like him,
but it's like,
man,
I have a hard time seeing all that.
I want to just throttle a guy like that and go,
look,
let's sit down and write down what the fuck is wrong with you and just work it
out for once and for all right,
let's not deal with this for 25 fucking more years.
Let's figure this shit out.
Frankie paste this thing,
man.
Exactly.
Exactly though.
Let's not go that better.
He's a fucking guy.
That guy I want.
He got mad at me once because I called him.
I said the old school comedy talent of Frankie Pace.
That's what I said,
old school and he doesn't understand that old school is like skills.
It was like,
no man is old school.
Like my man's an old school [inaudible] route karate guy.
You can say that to a dude,
they'll give me some knuckles,
he'd be laughing,
you know,
that's like a compliment.
But when I called him,
you know,
an old Mi ma,
he's sucks.
I shouldn't even said old school.
Like I said,
go on stage without your stupid fucking devil horns in your bag of shit and you
bring with you everywhere and then even a veto without the talent liability.
Here you go.
He's a kind of a human,
but it's the same thing.
It's like here's a guy who doesn't feel like there's enough positivity out there
and if he hasn't stockpile a big stash of it,
at least fucking kids,
they think they're funny.
You know,
I get to do was talk dirty.
So he goes on stage and introduces me after I introduced him with this old
school thing and he goes,
this guy thinks I'm old school and this and I and I,
and then he shits on me and he start shitting on my jokes is all before he
brings me up on stage.
So I go on stage.
I'm not even,
I didn't even know exactly how to handle him.
So I go on and say as I go,
first of all,
dude,
before I address any of what you just said,
so I just start talking him as he's walking through the crowd and go,
old school is a positive thing.
I go,
am I right folks?
And they start clapping.
I go,
it's like a rapper term.
when you say someone's older,
he goes,
variable that you must be new school.
I go,
are you trying to say that I'm not good?
They don't like me.
I go,
what are you trying to say?
So then I,
I start smiling and instead of getting upset at him,
I start mocking him.
I go from a,
how do you not like me?
Do you not like my comedy?
I go,
what's the matter?
it does it make you feel uncomfortable when people laugh harder at my shit than
yours?
And that's when he got fucking pissed off at me.
And he goes,
you fucking wish you were as good in me.
I go,
come on man.
We all just watched you.
You ain't that special.
I go,
didn't you guys see him?
you saw him,
right?
And then I,
I go,
what does he got like devil horns on and shit.
what was that?
It was that good.
Was that amazing?
Is that some breakthrough shit?
Like,
look at you,
you little fat.
Fuck.
And he goes,
you're going to look like me when you're my age.
I go,
do you think you look like me when you were,
you were my age.
Who would the fuck are you talking about?
What are you saying?
I'm,
I'm you.
You're me.
Or we won.
Oh my,
you're a cunt.
You're a cunt of a man.
Get out and get a bitter fuck to be like,
you'll look like this kind of a band.
He's that guy though.
He is the the guy you want to be.
Business owes me something that's business doesn't owe you a goddamn thing.
You know a lot of those guys on,
but it's like an old people always say too,
it's like Hollywood.
So it's,
it's so crazy.
It's so hard to make it.
It's the fairest business.
I know it never shoes talent away.
No,
no,
no.
Get out of here.
We don't age,
they never shoot talent away.
But those guys who can find all these things wrong,
whether it's the club booker or whatever,
like it's mostly at the comedy store,
you'll find guys,
it's like,
I'll always say him,
what other club is putting you on silent,
but I'll never get another club.
Well,
the comic store has got a fucking half a million assholes.
There really shouldn't be on stage,
but they're,
they've snuck into that system back in the 1970 [inaudible] stuck there.
You can go there any given night on a Monday or Tuesday and you'll see three or
four comics.
You can't fucking believe a professional comedian at the comedy store in
Hollywood.
Man,
when I was,
that's Mecca.
The best of the best and the worst of the worst.
The worst,
you know.
But beyond bad advocates,
high in the basement goes real fucking vape.
But you know,
a lot of room clears back in the day we would see them.
We would look at that.
That's the face you,
that's exactly what,
say you would look at the lineup,
you would see Freddy Lockhart and then you look at before you and UCL.
Ah,
there,
I remember when I worked the cover booth and I turned my shirt inside out
because I was embarrassed to work there because I have the answer to the likes
of ways like Billy and Rozzy on stage date year or whoever is putting on given
eulogies as they do and I remember you,
you drove the NSX and I,
I remember it was like if I saw that insects pulling up,
you were like the calvary.
It's like,
oh,
a legitimate bonafide comedian.
Oh real comedian that I can show what all these people that had to look in the
straight face in charge of $20 to see the likes of Dave here up there telling
why is it my cell phone worked with the antenna down but up.
It works.
What's wow.
Huh?
That was his closer,
well the poor guy,
he stopped doing comedy and he started doing some,
like I think you started doing some sort of humanitarian work or some point that
there's a really nice guy.
He was,
um,
I sold that guy.
My they,
sorry,
I switched at Dave title bar.
Oh,
it Davis
peer.
Honestly,
I don't even hear it was a sweet guy or I don't even remember his act.
He worked at the store too.
That really,
really,
really thin guy.
Real,
real skinny and funny.
I had a nice Volkswagen.
A sure Rocco.
Oh yeah.
I think that was what it was called.
No,
not the SIROCCO.
Maybe it was a Shrub,
whatever.
It was like a Volkswagen,
a pretty sweet Volkswagen.
And I started,
uh,
that's what we got.
Like one of my first development.
What year was this?
This was 94.
When I first came to Hollywood Volkswagen,
90 to 91 or something like that was a night.
It was a nice car.
I was in DC of course for my first new car and uh,
I got a super turbo and so,
uh,
I had this other car just laying around and you know,
Dave was telling me he needed my,
you know,
needed a car but he doesn't have any money.
I'm like how much money you got and you wind up giving me like a thousand bucks
for it or something like that.
I just gave it to him.
I forget what it was exactly,
but you know,
the car was worth like 10 grand.
Oh that's awesome.
Just gave it to him.
I take it he's a nice guy,
but he still drives that motherfucker and he lives in it now.
It's got 300,000 miles.
Right.
There is a,
there was a,
an interesting place because of that very reason though.
It's like it didn't dent the lesson of the comedy store was that there was no
rules there,
that it was chaotic and ridiculous and it made no sense.
And you know,
a guy like Eddie Griffin would go on at nine o'clock and stay on stage until
three o'clock in the morning.
Like all the time.
It's a pool with no lifeguard.
It's just there's just a bunch of kids swimming in summer jumping off the roof.
But because of that,
you know,
a lot of people develop that sort of habit of just going on stage and not giving
a fuck about the clock.
And I did too.
And I'm guilty of it for sure.
I did a lot of long sets.
They're doing them a favor though.
And you're also a guy who gave back to the club.
It's like,
you know,
there's little things that go without saying.
You give us a new roof,
a new sound system.
Let him run the light.
Charles Fleischer would give me a second jewel.
We appointed to 40 extra minutes.
Yeah.
What?
He was kind of crazy.
You know Fletcher says dude though he's,
he's out there.
He's like,
he,
he's been at the store lately.
I haven't seen it.
I think they banned,
they banned and we catch up every once in a while.
They ban.
Yeah,
something happened.
They stopped giving him sets.
Which one of these is yours,
man?
No kidding.
I haven't drank any of them saying,
oh yeah,
they stopped giving him sets something.
He got pissed and he started going over to laugh factor.
He's a genius.
He's up really fascinating dude to sit down and talk to,
I want to get him on the podcast.
I got his number,
one's at a Starbucks within my fucking blackberry,
fell on a toilet and I lost,
I lost it before I stored it and the computer,
I think I might have his number.
I'll give it a fascinating character.
And he's Steve.
He's the voice of Roger Rabbit for people don't know.
Yeah,
but he's also a scientist.
You know it was in the back of the comedy story.
He said he came up with some geometric new geometric structure and been working
on it for the last 36 days.
Yeah.
So working on this mathematical structure and then the fucking brought it in.
It was pieced together with a little plastic cause I go,
how long did it take you to put this fucking thing together?
He's like,
pieced it all together himself.
This weird multi sided geometric pattern.
I'm like,
wow,
what a,
what a weird guy.
Very weird,
but he's lived at his house,
looks like nuts.
He was married for a long time and now he's single,
you know,
and I think the,
I'm thinking he's one of those guys that probably when his wife left the house
instead of crying,
you probably like
now I can get to work and I can't go work on my machine.
I bet he has like a lave and all sorts of industrial.
It's like shit that just dudes don't have at home.
It's a lot of dudes like building things.
Man.
Adam Carolla has like a full cabinet tree,
like construction set up at his garage.
He's got the dopest place where he were.
Adam does his podcast.
He's got a killer studio set up where it's like couches and microphones and all
that.
Not a whole staff.
He has a staff of like when I was there there was like five or six people
working for him would manning the video cameras and working the phones and all
this different shit.
And then he's got this back area where he keeps his cars were also has carpentry
equipment and he's like build in fucking cabinets and shit.
He's a strange cat.
He's one of the weirdest,
the weirdest become.
I mean he is.
I would consider him a standup comic now.
He wasn't for a long time and now he is again.
He's one of the weirdest of those guys because he's such a,
he doesn't watch comedy.
He's not a fan of comedy,
but to him it's like he goes,
wow,
it's easy for me to do kind of go do it that on what?
They just fucking does it.
I never,
I never met him before.
It's funny.
Yeah,
he's great.
There's these guys been around forever and ever had met Tom Arnold racing did a
pilot with him.
He was,
he was super cool.
I had never,
I had no idea what,
you've got to catch them on the right mixture.
You know you might catch him when he's on some weed and he's friendly as flag
gacked out and wants to cut your fucking hard out with a fork.
I don't need my heart getting cut out with a fork cause I need to figure out a
network.
People would complain as the audio is fucked up Brian.
Yeah,
I was getting some reverb in my hair.
I didn't want,
I'm scared to test it.
All right,
well that's not good because then it's good on the MP three but that's what I
was playing with earlier.
Well how do we know what it sounds like on the Ustream?
See the problem is this laptop doesn't have any a headphone jack cause it only
has one jack for headphone.
He does this one have a headphone Jack.
Yeah,
but I mean if he,
if I can plug it in there and listen to her,
I can try.
Why don't you plug it in here?
I list.
What do you want to interrupt you?
You well I want to find out what's going on man.
Because with the last one was terrible.
Apparently I get mad at me mad.
You always just when you're retarded,
I was just playing with the level.
Totally not.
Okay.
Tell me what's going on now.
Now you're listening to and making sure you're,
hold on.
Hmm.
I'm talking to you Brian.
Michael,
and so use your,
my now is,
I'm getting a big spinning ball.
Ustream is very nice for having us on and all that good stuff,
but it seems like it kind of sucks.
It's a lot of complaints about it all the time.
Yeah,
it's free,
you know?
Yeah.
At least you don't have all the ads.
I,
yes.
It's all static and stuff.
Still.
How bad the sound
does it sound really bad?
Check a check.
It sounds shit like shit.
Why don't we disconnect it from that thing?
How much of a pain in the ass,
how long would that take?
Well,
the problem is is that it makes no sense at all.
The audio.
Damn.
Brian,
we can't have this.
Hold on.
This is 10 wait,
can I,
can I show you something though?
Here's the audio that you're computer's thing it sounds like.
Yeah,
the,
I understand that Brian,
but it's going okay.
This plug that's going in here.
It's the same club
chicken,
Brian.
I don't care.
What I'm saying is it sounds like terrible.
It sounds terrible for the people that are listening on Ustream,
so how do we fix that?
We're going to stop.
Won't be right back.
All right.
I'm going to stop,
folks.
All right.
We gotta fix this.
It was like that the whole time.